okay we have news of a major new
investigation into donald trump's
criminality which broke over the New
Year holiday and it has everything to do
with undocumented immigration and the
wall Trump wants to build and hypocrisy
which is sort of one of the key tenants
of this administration there is now a
New Jersey Attorney General
investigation into Donald Trump's Golf
Club in New Jersey not only hiring
undocumented immigrants we learned about
that in December we knew about that
already but giving the undocumented
immigrants that they hired fake green
cards and fake social security numbers
this is Donald Trump the guy who was
going to stop undocumented immigration
the guy who's strong on the wall with
Mexico which Mexico is going to pay to
build which obviously they're not going
to pay to build which now Trump wants
your money to build that wall that Trump
is so strong on that's the guy I'm
talking about we're talking about trump
National Golf Club where in New Jersey
we're an attorney representing several
undocumented immigrants who work there
is claiming that he has turned over
evidence to the New Jersey Attorney
General to robert muller and to the FBI
with evidence of undocumented employees
at Trump's Golf Club remember that's
already a crime hiring undocumented
immigrants they were given fake green
cards and Social Security numbers by
Trump's Golf Club now of course the
Trump Organization has immediately
denied knowingly hiring undocumented
workers that's an important issue here
because if they truly didn't know that
the employees were undocumented their
legal liability goes way down because if
you're not required to find out
immigration status and you don't know
you can make the case that you haven't
done anything wrong the problem with
that is that if you're providing fake
green cards and Social Security numbers
to people the veil of ignorance lifts
very quickly why would you give somebody
a fake green card if you have no idea
that they're in the country illegally
and of course the claims are that the
managers of Trump's facility were the
people doing this and that of course
we're eventually going to hear that
Trump had no idea about it
this was the manager
Trump didn't know about it they didn't
have his permission everybody's been
fired but the problem is Trump has
always said in business in politics the
buck stops at Trump that's who's
responsible until of course it's Trump
who's at the top and all of a sudden now
oh no this is an issue much lower down
the corporate organizational hierarchy
but what we really have to do once again
every time there's one of these stories
is step back and consider the absurdity
of Trump on immigration Trump got a ton
of attention at the start of his
campaign for proudly and loudly saying
he's going to stop those bad Hispanic
immigrants from coming here they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
and some Trump assumed or good people of
course some of them actually work for
Trump with fake immigration documents
allegedly provided to them by his own
business he's against chain migration
but Melania Trump parents are now
citizens of the United States because of
chain migration he's against people
working in the US illegally except his
current wife Melania Trump was in the
United States working despite being here
on a visa that did not allow work to be
done he says he wants to clean up this
problem of undocumented workers but he
doesn't do a thing about the companies
that are hiring them and he has a
history of hiring undocumented
immigrants how are you going to stop the
incentive for the immigrants to come to
the United States in the first place if
you're allowing companies to go
unpunished when they're actually doing
the hiring and then as far as the fake
green cards the weirdest thing about
that is who were they for in the sense
that fake green cards aren't going to
fool immigration authorities so were the
fake green cards to lull the
undocumented immigrants into a false
sense of security because if they
actually had an interaction with
immigration authorities their fake green
cards and fake Social Security numbers
would come up as fake immediately so I'm
kind of wondering even what what the
point of that was consider how far
things have degraded politically that in
the old days when Bill Clinton was
president
when Bill Clinton nominated people to
his cabinet some of them had to withdraw
nominations because it turned out they
hadn't paid a nanny's Social Security
taxes and the right said they must
cancel their nominations because of this
misdeed the current president's
companies gave undocumented employees
fake immigration documents and it's not
clear that there will ever be any
consequences for Donald Trump for having
done this the moral majority doesn't
really seem like it right send me your
thoughts on this the show is on
Instagram at David Pakman show i'm on
instagram at david pakman Bryant Welch
joins me next one of the day's sponsors
is privacy dot-com slash Pakman which is
a free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which
happens all the time it is all
completely free all you have to do is
click the link under this video to get
started and for a limited time they're
giving everyone in our audience $5
towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link